quelques questions ont été posées sur la
question sur les ressources et notamment
sur les gaz de schiste ça je vais quand
même me répondre
ordre de grandeur l'europe consomme
aujourd'hui 500 milliards de mètres
cubes de gaz par an là dedans 300
viennent de la mer du nord
le détail du calcul et sur mon site dont
je vous donne juste le résultat ce qu'on
pourrait obtenir des gaz non
conventionnel est de l'ordre de quelques
dizaines de milliards de mètres cubes
par an en europe
voilà c'est ça leur de grandeur sur une
consommation annuelle qui fait
aujourd'hui 500 je vais vous donner
maintenant un cas plus particulier qui
est celui de la france la france et 50
milliards de mètres cubes par an la
diana 30 dans le chauffage 15 dans
l'industrie si le seul problème c'est de
satisfaire les demandes des chimistes
français avec en conservant en 15 de
consommation de gaz naturel en france on
s'en sort sans problème
et la question est de supprimer les 30
qu'on a dans le chauffage qui soit dit
en passant nous coûte 6 milliards
d'euros d'importations parents et
s'assurer de l'isolation et les pompes à
chaleur
on n'a pas besoin de gaz pour ça donc
sortir le gaz et le fioul des usages
thermiques dans le bâtiment est une des
premières priorités à mon sens dans tout
conquête de la lune puisque moi c'est
comme ça que j'ai envie c'est le nom que
j'ai envie de lui donner et j'ai
d'autant plus envie de lui donner ce nom
laraque comme je les dis un certain
nombre de fois il va falloir demander de
l'effort à tout le monde et l'effort
partagé par tous n'est possible que
quand il ya un truc un peu excitant en
face donc quand vous dites à un
astronaute qui va aller sur la lune
il est d'accord pour se mettre pendant
une semaine dans une boîte de conserve
risquer sa vie pas voir sa femme etc et
tout ça parce qu'en face il ya un truc
il excite beaucoup bien je pense que si
on a pas et ça c'est votre métier je
suis désolé ce n'est pas le mien
si on n'a pas une vision exaltante à
long terme a proposé aux pays c'est pas
la peine de songer à la bonne manière de
lui demander des efforts on peut
bricoler poser des rustines etc
mais c'est c'est pareil et c'est
exactement le même sujet soit dit en
passant pour l'argent et je vais prendre
un exemple tiré de la vie courante
si un de vos enfants vient vous voir en
vous disant oh papa ou maman ou et
déconner non excusez-moi parents dans le
futur at-il donc papa ou maman j'ai
déconné et j'ai 500 euros de trous sur
mon compte en banque il faudrait boucher
vous allez traîner les pieds le faire
une fois parce que vous l'aimez bien
puis la deuxième vous allez commencer à
trouver que la plaisanterie a assez duré
l'homme aime bien vous voir une semaine
après en disant papa ou maman j'ai un
projet pour l'avenir et j'ai besoin de
10000 euros
vous les avez vous payez vous avez passé
un autre sujet vous avez vous payé
donc là on est exactement dans la même
configuration on n'arrête pas de se
demander où on va trouver l'argent pour
faire des trucs dans un an avec une
mentalité de bouchage avait deux pauses
de rustines on va bricoler et on
trouvera pas la moitié des machins dont
on a besoin
si on est dans une optique de conquête
de la lune l'argent c'est pas le sujet
l'argent c'est pas le sujet on trouve on
a trouvé mille milliards pour sauver les
banques
c'est pas le sujet ça c'est vraiment pas
le sujet ce qui est le sujet c'est
l'arbitrage car on n'aura pas de
l'argent pour tout et ça j'y reviens on
n'aura pas à la fois de l'argent pour
donner un travail à tout le monde
donnait de l'espoir à tout le monde et
donné plus de consommation à tout le
monde ça on leur a plu mais préserver la
stabilité socio économique du pays avec
de l'espoir et un travail pour tous ça
on trouve c'est vraiment pas le sujet